[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis einen schönen guten abend und
herzlich willkommen das wichtigste vom
sport hat
und wir beginnen mit corona die themen
umstrittene lockerung gemusterte wollen
die gesundheitsminister bundesweit von
der test pflicht bei 2g plus befreien
experten warnen das komme zu früh
gegen hass und hetze der staat muss
gegen den messenger-dienst telegramm
vorgehen fordern politiker und auch
kriminalbeamte
und straflager für blogger die kamov ski
ein gericht in belarus verurteilt den
ehemann von oppositionsführerin die ich
an oskar ja zu 18 jahren haft
neue regierung neue rat von corona
expertinnen und experten
heute ist er das erste mal
zusammengekommen er soll die ampel
koalition beraten und so der
bundesgesundheitsminister noch vor
weihnachten eine einschätzung abgeben
wie gefährlich die neue micon variante
ist heute hat sich lauterbach auch mit
den gesundheitsministerin und ministern
der länder getroffen sie beschlossen die
testpflicht für gepostete aufzuheben
simon franz sind berichtet
einfach mal spontan ins kino dass wir
hier in münchen zuletzt nicht mehr
möglich es gilt zweig plus geimpfte und
genesene brauchen einen aktuellen corona
test doch das soll sich jetzt bundesweit
ändern zumindest für alle die bereits
eine booster impfung erhalten haben wir
haben uns heute in diesem antrag darauf
geeinigt dass personen mit erhaltener
auffrischungsimpfung ab deren
vollständiger wirksamkeit von der tests
pflicht im rahmen der zweig plus
regelung befreit werden sollen das soll
15 tage nach einer dritten impfung
gelten boostern also statt testen doch
der beschluss ist umstritten weil die
omikron variante sich immer weiter
ausbreitet kritik kommt etwa von der
medizinerin ute teich hat es ist
verfrüht menschen mit booster impfung
von der test pflicht zu befreien es wäre
klüger abzuwarten wie sich die pandemie
in den kommenden wochen entwickelt doch
der neue bundesgesundheitsminister
verteidigt das vorgehen es ist
tatsächlich so dass jemand der frisch
geputzt hat ist ein sehr geringes risiko
trägt sich zu infizieren und dann noch
viel geringeres risiko trägt sich so zu
infizieren dass er für andere ansteckend
ist somit also ist das ein hohes
sicherheitsniveau in krankenhäusern und
pflegeeinrichtungen soll es weiterhin
test pflichten geben auch für menschen
mit booster impfung
[Musik]
immer wieder fällt der name telegramm
wenn es darum geht wo corona leute im
netz hass und hetze verbreiten telegramm
ist ein messenger dienst das heißt man
kann sich nach rechnen schreiben und
gruppen zum austausch bilden aus der
politik werden die stimmen lauter auf
telegramm den druck zu erhöhen gegen
hass nachrichten vorzugehen wieso das so
schwierig ist erklärt saara tacke
impfgegner gestern abend in mannheim
bereit zu gewalt
impfgegner und rechtsradikale in bautzen
auch gestern abend auch gewalttätig was
sie verbindet ist wie die sich verbinden
immer wieder nutzen sie zum
nachrichtenaustausch den
messenger-dienst telegramm
was auf telegramm passiert welche post
da gemacht werden nachrichten verbreitet
werden da ist hass und hetze dabei das
ist eine straftat wenn telegramm diese
dinge nicht beseitigt dann macht sich
telegramm selbst straftat die
gesetzlichen grundlagen haben wir dafür
telegramm muss verstehen in deutschland
hält man sich verdammt noch mal an
deutsche gesetze das problem viele
nutzen telegramm ganz legal um freunden
eine nachricht zu schreiben der anbieter
ermöglicht es aber auch dass sich bis zu
200.000 menschen zu einer gruppe
zusammenschließen und kontrolliert
eigentlich wäre telegramm nach dem
netzwerk durchsetzungs gesetz dazu
verpflichtet strafbare inhalte zu
löschen und demnächst auch straftaten zu
melden aber telegram ist bislang für den
deutschen staat nicht erreichbar der
springende punkt ist einfach die
mitwirkung der kooperationsbereitschaft
der anbieter und darauf ist das netzwerk
durch das gesetz sie auch angelegt und
wenn die blockieren dann haben sie in
der tat ein problem was ich an der
stelle eben einfach auf eine ganze
erschreckende weise wirklich zeigt den
deutschen behörden haben bereits zwei
bußgeldbescheide hierhin nach dubai
geschickt wo telegramm sitzen soll
bußgelder bis zu 50 millionen euro
könnten gegen teheran verhängt werden
doch deutsches recht das nicht
durchgesetzt werden kann ist machtlos
schauen wir auf die korona zahlen das
robert koch institut meldet eine leichte
entspannung die zahl der neuinfektionen
liegt bei 30
das sind 5000
236 fälle weniger als vor einer woche
weiteren hoch ist die zahl der toten
473 menschen starben im zusammenhang mit
kubik 19 die inzidenz gegen bundesweit
auf jetzt 3 175 zurück
unter den bundesländern gibt es jetzt
kein land mehr mit einem schnitt über
1000 an der spitze liegt thüringen der
geringste incidents meldet weiter
schleswig holstein
die meisten kurven infektion werden bei
kindern gezählt auch weil er den schulen
und kitas regelmäßig getestet wird so
liegt die inzidenz bei den fünf- bis
neunjährigen bei 951 und in der gruppe
der zehn bis 14 jährigen sogar bei mehr
als 1000 entlastung erhoffen sich jetzt
viele von der beginnenden kinder impfung
wachsende sorgen bereitet aber die wohl
noch ansteckender virus variante omikron
rote farbe informiert
nur auf dem tablet können wie eva sehen
ihre quarantäne endet erst kurz vor
heiligabend sie hat co wird erst
leichtes fieber jetzt ist die
siebenjährige wieder fit ihr vater hat
die aufnahmen gemacht neun kinder in
acht klassen hat es an evas düsseldorfer
grundschule erwischt man kriegt und mini
schock aber dann sagt man okay was hast
du eigentlich erwartet früher oder
später ist man quasi dran war ich oder
passiert es eben man bereitet sich vor
auf mehr stationäre fälle von kindern
sagt der leiter der kinderklinik an der
universität köln omikron bereitet sich
aus vieles aber sei noch unklar es ist
sicherlich so dass um mikro nach allem
was wir wissen deutlich ansteckender ist
es verdichten sich aber auch zunehmend
die daten dass die verläufe bei den
kindern nicht wie ursprünglich erwartet
schwerer verlaufen das wäre wenn sich
das alles bestätigt natürlich eine gute
nachricht
infektionen früh erkennen darum geht es
mancherorts auch mit pcr tests für die
allerkleinsten im düsseldorfer kitas
starten sie ab heute regelmäßig damit
die aussagen stimmen uns sehr positiv
dass es eine sicherheit von 95 bis 100
prozent gibt mit einer pcr test und dass
das auch im labor untersucht wird mehr
sicherheit finden auch eltern gut aber
nicht alle kommunen bieten pcr tests für
kita-kinder dafür reichen die
laborkapazitäten nicht aus
in großbritannien ist derzeit zu
beobachten was mit der omicron variante
auch auf uns zukommen könnte das virus
breite sich dort mit extremer
geschwindigkeit aus sagt der
gesundheitsminister
mehr als
4700 bestätigte omikron fälle gibt es
bereits zehn davon mussten im
krankenhaus behandelt werden eine person
starb und alle zwei tage verdoppeln sich
die fallzahlen familie johnson schwenk
deswegen um will nun doch wieder
schärfere corona maßnahmen noch am abend
will das unterhaus darüber abstimmen
yasin herrlein
lange schlangen vor britischen
impfzentren es muss jetzt alles ganz
schnell gehen mit dem boostern so ernst
ist die bedrohung durch die omikron
variante dass der premierminister selbst
nach dem rechten schaut
das wichtigste dass jeder einzelne jetzt
tun kann ist sich den booster geben zu
lassen dafür dass sich omikron auf der
insel so schnell ausbreitet könnten
mehrere faktoren verantwortlich sein
erst spät wurde mit dem impfen von
kindern und jugendlichen begonnen und
laut neuester studien sollen zwei dosen
astrazeneca mit denen sehr viele briten
geimpft sind kaum vor ansteckung
schützen zwei dosen biontech nicht
vielmehr erst die dritte
auffrischimpfung soll bei omikron
wirksamen schutz bieten
derweil ist prämiert johnson nach
zahlreichen skandalen stark angeschlagen
vor allem wegen mehrerer
weihnachtsfeiern in der downing street
im letzten jahr als ich das land im teil
locker und fand
damit seine autorität ist beschädigt er
ist geschwächt seine partei gespalten er
kann dem land nicht die führung geben
die es braucht er ist der
schlimmstmögliche primiz uhr
schlimmstmöglichen zeit ob wurst post
das wird johnson heute auch im parlament
zu spüren bekommt bei mehreren
abstimmungen über noch recht milde
coroner beschränkungen wie zweig für
veranstaltungen und masken pflicht
werden sich viele tores gegen ihren
parteivorsitzenden stellen dabei könnte
die insel wahrscheinlich noch viel
striktere maßnahmen gebrauchen um nicht
von der omicron welle überrollt zu
werden
zurück nach deutschland
da hat die cdu csu fraktion jetzt eine
verfassungsbeschwerde angekündigt gegen
den geplanten nachtragshaushalt der
ampel koalition der sieht vor dass über
60 milliarden euro nicht genutzter
kredite für die pandemie stattdessen in
ein klima und energiefonds fließen das
sei es schwer in einklang zu bringen mit
der schuldenbremse so
unions-fraktionschef brinkhaus am
donnerstag wird im bundestag über den
nachtragshaushalt beraten
und im bundestag gibt es auch streit da
die afg den vorsitz im wichtigen
bundestags-innenausschuss bekommen soll
welche partei in welchem ausschuss den
vorsitz übernimmt wird nach einer festen
reihenfolge entschieden so darf die
größte fraktion als erstes zu greifen
danach die zweitgrößte und so weiter da
alle andere größeren fraktionen andere
ausschüsse wählten griff die afg beim
innenausschuss zu und nominierte dafür
heute ihren vorsitzenden der kandidat
stößt auf kritik nicole diekmann
das ist martin hess ehemaliger polizist
mitglied der fdp bundestagsfraktion und
ab morgen vorsitzender des
innenausschusses zumindest wenn es nach
der fdp geht doch die vorbehalte der
anderen parteien sind riesig das weiß
auch hess zu guter letzt möchte ich den
sicherheitsbedenken die von seiten der
zumindest von teilen der medien und auch
von teilen des politischen gegners
geäußert worden sind entschlossen
entgegenzutreten entgegentreten ich
denke dass der vorsitz im innenausschuss
bei einem ehemaligen
polizeihauptkommissar mit 27 jahren
dienst erfahrung in guten händen ist
ausgerechnet die afd ausgerechnet an der
spitze des innenausschusses in seltener
einigkeit sich csu und linke entsetzt
für mich ist das deshalb schwierig weil
die afg in teilen vom verfassungsschutz
beobachtet wird und wir natürlich mit
dem innenausschuss nach der
ausschussvorsitzende wir kontrollieren
das innenministerium die nachgelagerten
behörden und dazu gehört auch das
bundesamt für verfassungsschutz für uns
ist es nicht normal dass eine partei der
extrem rechten überhaupt im parlament
sitzt und das ist für viele minderheiten
in diesem land genauso und wir sagen
ganz klar wir stehen an der seite dieser
menschen und das bedeutet auch wir
suchen natürlich morgen den konsens der
demokraten und demokraten dass wir
gemeinsam die afg in diesem wichtigen ab
verhindern womöglich wird es morgen
nicht gewählt die drähte der anderen
fraktionen laufen heute heiß wird er als
vorsitzender abgeschmettert wäre das ein
präzedenzfall
bei einfachen ausschussmitgliedern geht
das nicht deshalb gilt er als gesetzt
hat es genau kein familie tierischen
abschirmdienst als extremist
eingestufter soldaten schickt die afd in
den verteidigungsausschuss
sowohl die regierungsparteien als auch
die union hätten ja den vorsitz im
wichtigen innenausschuss übernehmen
können wie es tradition ist hat die
größte oppositionsfraktion cdu csu aber
den vorsitz im haushaltsausschuss
übernommen theo koll
haben spd grüne oder fdp nicht nach dem
vorsitz im innenausschuss gelassen nun
weil sie sich alle aus unterschiedlichen
gründen für andere ausschüsse mehr
interessiert haben die fdp wollte
verteidigung auch weil sie mit frau
strack-zimmermann eine ausgewiesene
expertin haben und die grünen haben sich
für den europa ausschuss entschieden
unter anderem weil dort das europäische
klima paket verhandelt wird aber
offensichtlich auch weil er anton
hofreiter der im kabinett leer ausging
sich den vorsitz gewünscht hat tja und
jetzt stehen sie alle betreten vor den
politischen scherben denn die afg hat
zugegriffen und beansprucht damit als
partei die ja in teilen vom
verfassungsschutz beobachtet und
möglicherweise bald komplett als
rechtsextremer verdachtsfall eingestuft
wird ausgerechnet den ausschuss in dem
über geheimdienste und extremismus
beraten wird und zwar mit vertraulichen
informationen es kann sein dass eine
ausschussmehrheit morgen den hfc
kandidaten ablehnt das wäre jedenfalls
absolutes parlamentarisches neuland und
selbst verschuldet herbeigeführt danke
für diese einschätzung theo koll sie
wenn es weiter für uns beobachten
sie ist eine der international
bekanntesten bilder russischen
oppositionsführer rinnen svetlana
tschechows kaya ihr ehemann sitzt seit
mai 20 20 im gefängnis seite erklärt hat
er werde bei der präsidentschaftswahl
kandidieren
jetzt ist er geht yanofsky zu 18 jahren
haft verurteilt worden dem blogger und
regierungskritiker werden die
vorbereitung und organisation von massen
aufständen vorgeworfen christian senn
berichtet als letzter der sechs
angeklagten wird sergej kirow ski in den
gerichtshof ich geführt demonstrativ
dreht er sich mit dem rücken zu den
kameras 18 jahre so lautet das urteil
gegen tieren oft der vorwurf unter
anderem organisation von massenunruhen
und anstiftung zu sozialem hass zum
verhängnis wurde ihm dass er lukaschenko
2020 als präsidentschaftskandidat
herausfordern wollte doch dazu kommt es
nicht kira noski wird festgenommen und
an seine stelle tritt seiner frau seit
lennox kaja die bis dahin mit politik
gar nichts zu tun hatte sie gilt als
wahlsiegerin der umstrittenen
präsidentschaftswahl musste aber vor dem
lukaschenko regime fliehen und kämpft
weiter für belarus und ihren mann ist -
das urteil bedeutet dass man tapferer
und wundervoller mann ein persönlicher
feind von lukaschenko wurde der hat
rache genommen wegen der starken
stellung meines mannes weil er für
millionen von bürgern ein anführer sein
könnte
das harte strafmaß das sonst nur männer
bekommen soll lukaschenko-gegner
abschrecken wer sich in belarus gegen
diktator lukaschenko stellt wird zum
staatsfeind erklärt landet im gefängnis
oder wird aus dem land gejagt die
oppositionsbewegung die im letzten jahr
einen demokratischen wandel wollte hat
keinen handlungsspielraum mehr mit
sergej kirow ski hier im weißen shirt
wird erneut ein prominenter
regime-gegner verurteilt aber in behla
russischen gefängnissen sitzen hunderte
weitere politische gefangene aus dem weg
geräumt von diktator lukaschenko
nach beschädigungen an einer moschee
ermittelt die leipziger polizei wegen
besonders schweren landfriedensbruchs
ein politisches tatmotiv wird nicht
ausgeschlossen nach polizeiangaben
wurden mehrere fensterscheiben der
moschee zerstört als montagabend und 70
menschen randalierend durch den
leipziger osten zogen bei zwölf von
ihnen habe man die personalien
festgestellt und
wir kommen zum sportstar frauen haben
bei der em in spanien aber da liegt ja
bisher ganz gut für österreich aus dem
fünf siege und nur eine niederlage in
der gruppenphase tolle leistung heute
abend geht's in die ko runde
viertelfinale gegen die noch
ungeschlagenen gastgeberinnen ein sieg
und die erste deutsche wm-medaille seit
2007 wäre in greifbarer nähe die warme
mittelmeer sonne für die deutschen
handball frauen nur ein grund noch ein
bisschen länger in barcelona zu bleiben
überwiegend starken turnier leistungen
machen hoffnung nach 14 jahren endlich
wieder ins halbfinale einzuziehen nur im
letzten hauptrundenspiel gegen dänemark
die dhb auswahl schwach muss sich nun
also wieder steigern und fühlt sich in
der außenseiterrolle durchaus wohl die
ganze halle gegen ein das motiviert
vielleicht noch mal zusätzlich der druck
liegt auf jeden fall bei den spaniern
das könnte vielleicht für uns ein
kleiner pluspunkt sein ein weiterer alle
deutschen spielerinnen sind fit gute
aussichten also für einen längeren
verbleib im sonnigen barcelona
ioc präsident thomas bach war scharf
kritisiert worden für die kommunikation
rund um den fall der chinesischen
tennisspielerin rang zwei heute äußerte
er sich erstmals dazu in einem zdf
exklusiv-interview
um sie sorgt sich die sportwelt die
wimbledon siegerin war zeitweise aus der
öffentlichkeit verschwunden nach
vergewaltigungs-vorwürfen gegen ein
parteifunktionär sportler forderten
konsequenzen ioc präsident bach führte
anfang dezember ein videotelefonat
bestätigte heute weitere gespräche und
so
haben wir diese zumindest diese sorge um
die körperliche unversehrtheit die das
oberste
menschenrechte ist
nehmen können und wir werden diesen
kontakt auch weiter aufrecht erhalten
die frauen tennis tour wta spielt
vorerst keine turniere in china das ioc
setzt auf diskrete diplomatie ein
persönliches treffen soll es im januar
geben
und das komplette interview mit dem
ioc-präsidenten finden sie auf
sportstudio de im sommer 2023 finden in
berlin die special olympics statt die
weltspiele für menschen mit geistiger
und mehrfacher behinderung acht
wettkampftagen über 7.000 athletinnen
und athleten aus rund 170 ländern 26
sportarten heute die vorstellung des
logos fröhlich bunt lebendig und
vereinen zusammen und unschlagbar
zusammen werden übrigens auch zdf bei
dir und auch private sender diese welt
spiele übertragen
und jetzt wird's nochmal weihnachtlich
fröhliche weihnacht überall in
hürtgenwald bei aachen geht das sogar
für eine radarfalle denn die haben
unbekannte umdekoriert vor
geschwindigkeit dann gibt es ein foto
als geschenk die polizei nahmen's
gelassen stellte keine anzeige und
rückte den rot gewandeten etwas zur
seite damit er nicht mit aufs bild kommt
wenn jemand mit motorisiertem schlitten
daher gerauscht kommt
jetzt schauen wir noch kurz aufs wetter
etwas sonne ist morgen dabei aber die
wolken überwiegen alle einzelheiten dazu
gleich von ist intelli das heute-journal
können sie um 21 45 sehen mit bettina
schausten schönen abend machen
[Musik]